[Music]
okay everybody I am so so excited today
because I have with me
Aya furukoa who plays natsuki in The
Midnight Club we're gonna be talking
spoilers about the whole season make
sure you watch the show first and then
come back to this interview how you
doing today Aya I'm doing really good
how are you good I love the gaming chair
you got you look all ready to go for
this it's an honor oh yeah
I I wanted to uh bring up just starting
off there's so many crazy things that
happen with natsuki in this story but I
really really love episode one and the
story she's in the middle of telling
with all these crazy jump scares so it's
really cool though that we see natsuki
scaring Spence in the story in the
street how did you pull off the scene on
the street with the multiple versions of
natsuki right yes we did have I
other body doubles so everyone is
dressed up as ghost version of me but
even before then we spend a couple days
doing some stunt rehearsals uh
specifically for Chris Spence he
basically had to learn how to fall
um so that you know he wouldn't hurt
himself on the pavement and for myself
it was just a matter of like learning
kind of
yeah the blocking of the whole thing so
a lot of it was just done by piece by
piece though so it wasn't really too
much for me to have to memorize or
anything yeah and that's awesome that
you get to see a bunch of people playing
the ghost version of you that's really
cool and the the ghost version just came
out awesome especially with the makeup
too so really cool stuff and but one of
my favorite moments is actually right
after you kind of are in the middle of
telling the story and you see that she
gets to slam the table and scare Sandra
here
um was that ever improvised it comes off
so well did you get to kind of have fun
with that a bit oh my God I wish I
improvised that but no it was totally
scripted
um you know we just had to make sure
that the kind of timing of that was
clean we had to do a few takes of that
um because you know if I'm anticipating
it too much it kind of loses the point
of like the screams so it was kind of
just that sort of setup yeah no you do a
killer job not only with that but when
you have to crawl on the table and also
scare Spence just really really great
and I love to uh it's always great about
Flanagan shows that you can go back and
re-watch and catch more and on my second
rewatch there's a lot I caught with
natsuki and one of the things was in
episode two we see natsukis working out
reading her story that we'll see later
on Road to Nowhere to Tris so
we don't know much about Tris so but for
you as an actress playing natsuki did
you kind of make a backstory for Tristan
Nazi's relationship that we didn't see
on screen
absolutely like there was a whole kind
of backstory I had for Tris especially
because
um that scene between me and Tris and
Mark
um when I'm first telling the story was
actually one of the audition scenes that
I had so
during that I kind of built a whole back
story that Tris you know was kind of the
first person who introduced me to Bright
Cliff like in the sense of uh she was
the one to give me the tour and she was
probably the one to also bring me into
the Midnight Club and was kind of the
warm welcome that you know she brought
especially because I think natsuki
herself can be like a little anxious or
you know she obviously has some like
insecurities and stuff I think trist was
someone who really brought Comfort to
her instability and being there in the
group so yeah yeah and I would I would I
totally think that sounds accurate too
because for natsuki to open up in such a
personal deep story like that it must
mean a lot of trust with Tris so I also
like to in episode three we learn more
about natsuki and that at Family Day we
learned her father passed in the war she
mentions though this picture that she
has her Father Day before his Ambush is
important to her why did you see that
specific picture important to her
I think that's just one of the last faux
of her dad kind of you know alive that
was one of the last ones that were taken
and you know being a military brat
basically
um with natsuki she would have moved
around a lot she probably wouldn't have
much of a community and
um her dad was probably not around us
much
so I think that's you know kind of one
of the few connections she has one of
the few things that she has to still
hold on to this like
memory of her dad so yeah no and I
really like that answer and it adds so
much to the character of natsuki and
it's interesting while I love about this
storyline with natsuki through the show
is that more and more is getting added
your character a little by little each
episode and episode five we kind of see
relationships kind of forming with her
from our angle and we see she Winks at a
mesh in episode four was she just losing
patience with him at this point like did
she ever believe you make the first move
or she's just kind of someone who kind
of takes what she wants kind of thing I
think at that point she has been staying
at right Cliff for I think three months
um which was introduced in like episode
one but I think she was kind of just
losing her patience with amesh I feel
like natsuki you know she is a person
that takes charge and she initiates a
lot of the engagement between imagine
that ski but
um you know she still wants some sort of
initiative from a mesh and some sort of
you know just to know that he's enjoy
interested but he yeah he's a bit of a
bit of a wuss about going about that so
yeah it was definitely a matter of
patience
um being broken at that point I was
actually so nervous to do that scene
because first of all I have to be like
really smooth and I'm like God I don't
know if I'm that kind of person
and also just like winking on camera
like I've never winked on camera I'm
like what if it looks awful what if I
don't know how to bling uh wink I mean
and I just blink instead but um yeah
yeah no that's great no it was a great
wink too prop so also to episode five
it's perfectly leads and so now we get
to see you play Becky in a mesh's story
so it's also interesting too because
even episodes before that we see you
appear as different characters and the
other uh Club story so what was your
favorite like other character to play
and maybe any fun stories from set on
those days because it looks crazy oh
yeah you know so much happened during
those times of shooting
I mean I gotta say like Teresa is
definitely like my favorite because you
know the whole storyline with Road to
Nowhere was really centered on my
character and me and you know well it
was very personal and stuff as well
um but besides Teresa I think
uh cheerleader Patty was my favorite
playing the mean girl was really really
fun
um especially with like the long wig
I've never had like long hair like that
before so everyone kept saying that when
I put on the wig I'd become another
person like something just possessed me
right just like really playing it into
uh the whole like um yeah the
cheerleader aesthetic the queen bee kind
of stuff so yeah no
I think that's awesome too about yeah
and I think it's awesome about you and
the whole cast is that you guys are able
to pull off so many different types of
Parts too which is really yeah
impressive
um so also a big moment on rewatch I
noticed too was in episode six when
we're seeing this ritual happen for Anya
that the sacrifice that
um we see natsuki is choosing to give is
something from the car that we know what
ends up happening with her in that car
but that she almost died in that car do
you think though she ever considered her
father's dog tags we always see her wear
for that Sacrament because that's what
was kind of running through my head
mm-hmm I think so because it is a very
significant piece to her she wears it
yeah and every single episode and every
moment I think besides when she's asleep
she has it on her bedside but it's
that's a tough question because I think
um should probably use the
the car keys because
that was probably something that was on
her mind and it was something that she's
never shared to anyone in the group
but the dog tags
I don't know at least me as a person and
maybe not speaking from like natsuki
that just seems too precious to let go
of even you know for something like that
it's the last piece of her dad that she
has with her all the time so it's like I
don't know how much I'd want to let go
of something like that for sure
yeah that's like the item that if she
dropped in the fire she might go grab it
right away yeah immediately regret it
and I think
yeah it would be just too much for her
emotionally to like do that no for sure
and and you just mentioned earlier too
the Teresa episode Road to Nowhere right
where's your Play Teresa but you know
this is the big natsuki episode
um it's brilliant and so much as your
performance and I like too that they
decided the writers to have natsuki just
to tell this to a mesh I think it made
it so much more personal and hit better
but it's dealing with stuff like
depression suicide so when you first
read this episode in the script were you
nervous about something like this is it
something that makes you toss and turn
at night before you film it or do you
kind of just embrace it like okay I'm
ready let's do this oh absolutely like
it was something I was really nervous
about
um mostly because it is you know even
though it's part of the story it's a
very real thing that affects people day
to day in their everyday lives
um and it's you know it's a hard topic
to come you know to bring up to talk
about to and also do it to do right to
do justice too I think you know we
really wanted to be sensitive to you
know everyone who has experienced this
it's not like a fake diagnosis it's like
real it's very it affects everyone in
their everyday lives
um I know you know to Julia who was one
of the writers of that episode she for
her that was a very personal story as
well so there was a lot of heart put
into that so yeah I was definitely
nervous and scared of doing it but
I think so long as I you know did my
research so long as I put my heart into
it and myself
I was kind of at ease about it so I'm
glad it turned out the way it turned out
so yeah it turned out great and I'm
wondering too as an actress you know
just for people who act too and do this
as well when you start getting and how
you're going to approach it and reading
the script what is it like then when you
you got to play around with some
Flanagan All-Stars here with Henry
Thomas and Alex Esso did you guys kind
of have to get all on the same page then
on like what Freedom Jack and poppycorn
really were what was where you guys were
even like in what reality like did you
guys have conversations about her you
kind of just meet and let it all kind of
hit each other we did kind of just meet
and you know let I let them you know
obviously it's not my position to tell
them what to do or anything so they
brought themselves to it and you know
they did a splendid job as poppy foreign
Freedom Jack you know they're amazing
you know veteran actors so all I could
do is kind of just sit there and take it
in and you know try to give back as much
as they give me but um yeah like Alex
was very sweet she was very encouraging
and Henry is very funny so
um we had a good time with that but no
there wasn't any real like discussion
prior but I think the characters were
pretty straightforward in the script
anyways that's you know kind of the
angel devil on your shoulder kind of
situation so yeah no for sure and it was
cool also to see you get to play Freedom
Jack and Poppy corn for a bit oh yeah
just that I was to your roster of
characters yeah no great a great job on
that too and I I do want to just just
commend you though the to me you
delivered one of my favorite lines of
the show so beautifully when natsuki
says I thought I wanted to die but then
I survived and realized how much I
wanted to live
um what is your process like as an
actress to get to a place of living life
because half of that's the writing but
the other half is you delivering that
perfectly how do you get there how do
you get to there emotionally
thank you so much for saying that
um yeah in terms of getting there
it's hard to say I mean
natsuki herself and like her background
as a character is so much I think
me when I was younger so you know a lot
of that
wasn't something that I had to dig for
or search it was more so you know my
experiences in my life like you know
struggling with mental health stuff as a
young teenager and like you know how
overwhelming the world can be at that
time so I think just thinking back on
like those moments or you know bringing
just making sure I'm bringing kind of
myself and my authenticity and like what
you know my truth of my experiences to
that moment was just what that was
I I really didn't know what that scene
would have turned out to be in you know
my preparation you know I do I try to
like do as much research as I can trying
like you know do all this prep but in
the moment you just kind of let go and
just see what comes up naturally and try
not to like
suppress it in any sort of way so
did you have to do a bunch of takes of
that was that something you had to do a
lot or is it like
no no I think you know one of The
Producers uh Adam fasulo he was very
kind to say you know if this is too much
in the moment we can always take a break
and step away from you know what was
going on because yeah it was a very
heavy topic but you know we only did I
think a few like maybe three or four
takes of each each take and stuff and
you know it can be very intimidating
with like uh some of like the dolly
pushes towards my face so I'm like
saying this monologue and stuff but
um I gotta say like saurian is such a
tremendous scene partner that he
he made it easy you know as someone to
like you know Express all that too so
sure yeah I love that and
also just talking about collaborating
like you're talking about with the actor
of amesh also is there anything because
like Mike Flanagan is so popular now he
is got so much credibility in the hard
world people respect him he's a horror
genius but you get this privilege that
not many people ever get to say that
they have to work with him so is there
anything you learn from working with
someone like a Mike Flanagan
something I learned in particular I mean
um one of like the pieces of advice was
just to like play a lot more and to like
make my own choices
um this was like the first time I've
ever been able to like play you know
obviously a lead character like natsuki
and someone who's so well-rounded
um I felt a little lost at times of like
what you know what am I supposed to
bring what am I you know you tell me
what I need to bring is always my
Approach for being on set but you know a
lot of that he's he mentioned like you
know whatever suggestions you had it was
very much a collaborative process which
was something that was really new to me
to kind of bring my own ideas and kind
of play around sometimes on set so
that's kind of something I learned I
think yeah no that's great and that's
that makes complete sense that that
would be kind of the vibe on set so
awesome to hear that and the good news
for you know fans are going to be
obsessed with you now I is gonna be back
though in the Flanagan verse on Netflix
with Fall of the House of Usher is there
any teas or just anything it's gonna be
crazy you can kind of give us about it
oh geez I wish I could you know tell you
more about Usher but all I can say it's
like I think all I can say is that it's
like a kind of rock and roll it's a lot
like there's it's gonna be extravagant
it's gonna be
yeah very interesting very different
from Mike's other work as well so but
still with like the Mike Flanagan Touch
of course but love it I can't wait for
that so in the meantime though everyone
watch I just crush it in the midnight
club now on Netflix and like I said
re-watch it just keep re-watching it
you'll catch so much more stuff
especially with natsuki and watch this
incredible forms Aya thank you so much
for joining me today and I hope to talk
to you in the future yeah thank you